des matchs d'improvisation théâtrale
intercollèges déclic théâtre a souhaité
maintenir le cycle mise cette année
l'événement a pris place à la merise de
trappes pour se préparer
les collégiens ont eu des cours en visio
autre particularité de cette édition
seuls des matchs intra collège ont eu
lieu l'événement était l'occasion de se
rencontrer pour la première fois de
l'année les enfants ont dû s'adapter
rapidement
avec cette année compliquée l' arrivée
aujourd'hui au spectacle la plupart ils
étaient très contents mais très stressé
parce que c'est ça non il ya un premier
match entre eux au collège et un
deuxième match avec un autre collège il
rencontre d'autres personnes c'est
magique vraiment les matches c'est
magique ça les fait progresser sa leaf
évoluer là ils sont passés d'un petit
match sans patinoire sans musique avec
très peu de public à ça aujourd'hui
six collèges ont participé à l'événement
les collèges le village courbet et
gagarine de trappes la mare au sol de
coignières les soldes lui en cours et
giacometti est de montigny le bretonneux
ça fait plaisir à tous les arabes ont
dit des choses au talent éclectique ça
fait plaisir de travailler avec eux ça
fait deux ans ont fait plus de matches
avec de la musique et caetera et la
croix rouge avec de la musique et voir
du public surtout c'est bien de chat
pour la chaîne
six matches ont été organisées entre les
collèges pour la finale l'objectif de
l'événement conclure les ateliers
d'impro des collèges et surtout finir
l'année sur une note positive et hostile
où on a subi voilà bah la visio pour
faire du théâtre les deux me jauger pas
mal de contraintes liées à l'épidémie
et bien en fait ouais il fallait que
tout le monde tous ceux qui étaient là
il fallait qu'ils puissent en profiter
donc loi était juste pouvoir jouer en
fait et montrer qu'on peut y être et
être heureux d'y être
au total une centaine de jeunes se sont
rencontrés à la merise pour cette 22e
édition
[Musique]